In the last few years, Kevin Costner has transformed
himself from a big-screen legend into the
small-screen star of one of the most watched
shows on television Paramount Network's modern-day
Western melodrama Yellowstone.
Costner portrays John Dutton, the head of
a Montana ranching dynasty whose lusted-after
land borders the titular national park and
a reservation occupied by indigenous peoples.
"What's he saying?"
"He says that it's wrong for one man to own
all this.
And that you should share it with all the
people."
While Costner has always brought a certain
movie-star swagger to Yellowstone, the series
has set itself apart from its competition
by taking advantage of its setting to infuse
a big-screen verve into its narrative.
As it happens, the show's Montana setting
was one of the biggest deciding factors for
Costner to make his first appearance on a
serialized TV series.
Speaking at Deadline's The Contenders Emmys
presentation in April 2019, Costner revealed
that the reason he agreed to star on Yellowstone
had everything to do with its location, which
he felt would remind audiences of the beauty
of the real world.
He said:
"The idea of seeing wide open spaces, when
the land was almost like the Garden of Eden
[...] To know that places like this still
exist in our country, adding drama against
its backdrop, and actually understand in the
realest terms that the meat that arrives on
our table is still coming from somewhere [...] We
don't see that enough.
I don't think that we get outside enough,
if you will."
Yellowstone is hardly Costner's first brush
with the wide open spaces of the American
West, or even the Western genre for that matter.
The actor has frequently saddled up and hit
the dusty trails over the course of his career,
breaking through in the 1985 actioner Silverado
before appearing in 1994's Wyatt Earp and
later producing, directing, and starring in
2003's Open Range a cinematic trifecta that
Costner had previously tackled to the tune
of two Academy Awards when his wispy, anti-Western
drama Dances With Wolves graced screens back
in 1990.
"I've always wanted to see the frontier."
"You want to see the frontier."
"Yes, sir.
Before it's gone."
In 2017, Costner revealed that he had co-written
a 10-hour-long Western project that he'd love
to direct for the big or small screen.
Speaking with Vulture, he shared:
"I have another Western I've co-written with
some people, and I would like to play out
the second half of my career directing more.
I've constantly given the movies I've found
to directors who I thought could do it better,
but there are a lot of voices in my ear from
my family saying, 'You need to direct the
movies you fall in love with.'
So I think I will."
As for Yellowstone, the show continues to
make stark use of its stunning vistas, which
serve as a fascinating backdrop and counterpoint
to its modern-day setting.
Though Costner hasn't yet helmed an episode
of the series, you can go ahead and add it
to the list of his memorable Western ventures
with the actor bringing as much drama, presence,
and majesty to the show as the Montana sky
itself.
You can also rest assured that Paramount Network
brass and series creator Taylor Sheridan will
be making full use of both on Yellowstone's
already greenlit third season.
Yellowstone's second season took a swing-for-the-fences
mentality in terms of its many narrative arcs,
and its finale delivered definitive ends to
a couple of the series' more compelling storylines
with a mix of shootouts, kidnappings, and
plenty of mano-a-mano-type fisticuffs.
Though producers have already gone on record
that season 3 of Yellowstone will likely level
off a bit in terms of sub-manic melodrama
and unabashed bloodletting, it's a safe bet
that the show will still be steeped in searing
political and personal dramas for season 3.
What also won't change on Yellowstone season
3 is its stunning, sprawling Montana landscape
that Costner and series fans love so much.
After all, the Duttons are far from done defending
their land from outsiders and competitors
and a handful of new faces are coming to Big
Sky Country for the new season.
These include Lost alum Josh Holloway and
The New World star Q'orianka Kilcher.
Season 3 of Yellowstone is currently in production,
and is set to premiere on June 17, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.